the NFL draft analyst for Bleach report
Matt Miller on the program how are you
Matt
oh well rich and yeah our Deann Indy
okay
ready to go man it's a crazy week okay
are you already seeing people out and
about how have you seen the Cowboys bus
in the city yet have you seen that yet I
think they Cruise in a little bit later
than the rest of us if I'm gonna see it
it'll be it like 3 o'clock in the
morning you know like tonight cuz you
don't see that during the day it's like
a vampire all you got to do is just see
Glaser sticking his head out the window
waving to people that's just looks like
ways I know I don't know how to get a
ticket on that bus one of these days
I'll make it to that point going man
keep going bleacher reporters we know
only gets bigger and better we know that
so where do you have the I know because
I've seen your list but I will ask it
for folks who might be curious just
about these two players because you have
come up with your top fifty as well as
the top 15 players in each position the
Haskins Murray equation how do you have
it equaling out tide right now honestly
and I know people are like you've been
watching these guys for nine months how
can you have them tied but but I do it
because I heard you talking about it on
the intro until December when he won the
Heisman Trophy everyone told me at
Oklahoma and the big 12 agents I don't
worry about calimary don't waste time
evaluating him when you have 400 other
guys to watch he's playing baseball so I
just enjoyed watching him as a fan of
college football and didn't break down
any of the tape and then there was this
try to hurry up and get him into the mix
and get the game footage to watch and
I'm really intrigued by him he breaks
every mold that I've ever seen or set
for quarterback evaluation he's gonna
come in even if it's just a hair under
5k and he's gonna be under 510 I'm
curious to see how big his hands are you
know people like to point to Russell
Wilson as a cop for him but Russell
Wilson had 10 and a half inch hands
which is like the size of a six foot
five or six foot six person not a guy
who's 510 with duane ask him
i love the the things we saw from him
the last three weeks of the season he
had a run against michigan northwestern
and washington - in the year against
three very good defenses and he played
his best football of the year in those
big moments and against good
defenseless so I love the way that the
season ended with him we haven't seen
either guys throw really since then
though because they weren't senior bowl
eligible we haven't seen you know behind
the looks things of what they're doing
so whether or not we see Kyler Murray I
doubt we see him do anything here but I
think this is an event where join
Haskins can come out and solidify his
stock is maybe the top top ranked
quarterback in this draft because he
does plan to throw and work out and go
through the process here you don't think
Carla Murray snowing on Saturday I do
that probably but it doesn't now be
surprised Oh Matt I'll tell you right
now that would be surprised the NFL
Network I'll tell you that that'd be
that'd be nice
I hope of course I mean look I'm biased
because I've been part of a broadcast
that he only thankfully gets bigger and
better every year with the hard work and
crew that puts together the entire
production it makes no sense to not
throw I mean it just get out there and
throw in the whole business of you don't
know what you're throwing - it doesn't
matter Scouts aren't there saying well
that ball was higher that ball you just
want to see the guy have the ball in his
hands step back see the footwork that's
what matters and then to see how fast
the ball jumps out of his hand when
that's all everyone last year was
talking about was Baker Mayfield how the
ball flew out of his hands and how the
ball arrived with such zip it kind of
surprised a lot of people in person and
I would love to see Carla Murray do all
of that that said in my estimation
what's the most important thing and
haven't been around the combine as ever
is the eye in the sky for the tape and
then the interview process when a team
looks at somebody and and hears them
talk about football and how smart they
are on the Greece board that said we're
gonna be talking about the measurements
all day long what's more important to
you Matt hand size or height I think
hand size because we've seen a height
breakdown and you just mentioned Baker
Mayfield Russell Wilson Drew Brees those
guys are they're under six foot two
which when I started this job eight
years ago that was the threshold you had
to be six foot two we've seen that
change and I think you can be creative
enough to get a guy moving around to
find passing
window if you have a small hands I think
not only do you have fumble concerns but
you know I've talked to you guys before
I actually had this conversation with
ruff some at his combine was that he was
able to put so much velocity on the ball
because he had big hands and I know
they're guys like Baker and Pat mahomes
who don't have the largest hands in the
world but they're both over that
nine-inch threshold so with with tyler
murray one thing that i would want to go
back and see and i have the numbers in
front of me he didn't fumble a lot but
how many hard hits did he take behind a
defensive line there excuse me an
offensive line that will have four
players drafted his left tackle left
guard right guard and right tackle will
be drafted so how many hits did he take
where you would think look at that CEO
that that type of hit could create a
fumble in the NFL no marcus mariota at
someone that stood out as not having
very big hands having fumbling problems
in college now he has those same issues
in the NFL so when I look at it like I
feel like what height you know we can
make a guy move around enough to find
those passing windows to make creative
plays and tyler murray is such a great
athlete he's gonna be able to do that
but when it comes to hand size if you're
gonna have trouble holding onto the ball
we'll probably see him get to Jared Goff
treatment you know the squirt in the
water bottle on the bowl when it comes
to pro day workouts and private workouts
because that is going to be a question
work for him Matt Miller bleacher report
here on the Rich Eisen show and in each
of one of the position groups and your
bleacher report posting you also have
other than just 1 through 15 on your
board biggest riser and biggest faller
you've gotten the quarterback position
drew Locke of Missouri is the biggest
riser in will Grier of West Virginia is
the biggest fall or why you know
watching those two guys together it's a
Senior Bowl you don't you don't want to
look at the Senior Bowl and learn
everything from there but you want to
take some notes away from there will
Grier just did not look like he had the
arm talent or the accuracy he was very
inconsistent which matches up with what
we saw the last couple years at West
Virginia and when you've played in that
Dana Holgorsen scheme I think as an
evaluator you have concerns about his
ability to hit passes you know on time
in tight windows where you can really
have to throw your guy open he didn't do
that well mobile
I thought drew lock on the other hand
was the most impressive quarterback of
the 8 that we saw there you know
very strong arm very athletic you know
he has it in his head that he's the next
Patrick mahomes and I wish he would stop
doing the no-look passes and practice
but he has some some traits and some
gifts that are really special I think
it'll be a lot like Josh Allen last year
where maybe the tape wasn't great and
the guys below 60% completion percentage
but the arm talent the athleticism and
the character are good enough that you
would bet a top-10 pick on him whether
you're the Denver Broncos or someone
else it does really feel like Drew locks
gonna be an early pick you know and I
was watching so much of the bowl games
as we all do and I watched Benny Snell
for Kentucky just absolutely dominate
Penn State and you have him as your
biggest follower and your running backs
group to the point where I don't even
see him your top 15 what's that all
about yeah it was hard this year with
the the running back position because
there's so many good ones so I apologize
- Benny snow I just couldn't get him in
the top 15 I when I watched him I saw
like a powerful runner but someone who
can be a bit for netiquette times you
know he doesn't see the hole and always
explode through it it's not always a
smooth transition for him too often it
you know he just runs violent into his
offensive line he could be impatient so
I liked his game and you're right he was
one of the most productive players in
the SEC last year and in the entire
nation but I looked at him as like a guy
who's an NFL backup unless he gets in
just a perfect system where it can be a
great fit for what he does is an
inside-outside runner but you know the
limitations in terms of you know he
doesn't catch the ball very well hasn't
shown a lot of aptitude as a pass
blocker and that's where the league's
going even if you're Todd Gurley or say
Kyle Barkley like you're gonna be
expected to block and you're going to
expected to catch the ball coming out of
the backfield and that's probably his
weakest aspect right now I'll be curious
to see how fast he actually runs you -
okay and Nick Bose is your undisputed
number one player correct yeah that was
easy I had someone tell me a years back
that the great players are easy to scout
and that's Nick Bosa I know he's been
hurt and he could have concerns about
that even with this you know his brother
has been banged up a little bit in the
NFL but so what he does is an outside
pass rusher it's just special he's a
great athlete and you can tell that he's
taken to the coaching that he's got
because
is very very developed for a prospect
yeah and for top edge rushers matt
miller bleacher report you've got Bosa
as most NFL ready best pass rusher and
best potential that's a heck of a triple
threat right there not that I know and
I've heard yeah right so there's no
there's no chance Arizona passes up on
on him correct there's no chance Larry
I've learned to never say never write
because too many crazy things can happen
but what you'd think that well you're
gonna hear man I mean as you know
Murray's gonna I think look good and at
the combine which means he's only gonna
look even better at his pro day and it's
just gonna get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger for him and
then the video of Kliff Kingsbury saying
what he's gonna say is gonna be what he
said you know prior to playing Oklahoma
as Texas Tech's guy and he could have
been doing the typical Lou Holtz talking
up rice but that's no rice that he was
playing you know and and and that's
gonna be how we fill some of the time
certainly if this draft is gonna be all
about tackles and and and edge rushers
which isn't the sexiest thing to be very
honest yeah the best thing that happens
to guys like ourselves to make money
talking about the NFL draft of Tyler
Murray because this was a boring dress
until until he got in it and that like
for me whether it's on my own podcaster
when I come to radio show those people
that's all we've talked about for two
months is this the mystique of Cuyler
Murray and whether he'll go to Arizona
if you buy into what cliff Kings very
said what happens to Josh Rosen would
the Raiders trade Derek Carr I mean
there's a million scenarios and I think
he is honestly tyler Murray is the
domino were waiting to see fall the rest
of the draft is usually pretty easy to
figure out in the first five or six
picks but he has made it interesting
this year where it feels like teams
could fall in love with the aptitude
that he brings and the fact that he
could be a difference maker at the
position if that's the case then you
could say I don't think it's crazy to
see an Arizona or Oakland say hey this
guy can get us somewhere that Derek Carr
can't or Josh Rosen won't so let's start
over with this head coach especially if
you're Arizona higher Kliff Kingsbury
you got to let him run it off in what
was I don't I don't know if Josh Rosen's
that guy yeah I mean cuz last
for you on this subject even though I
know I'm playing into what you said
every single conversation you've been
having is is that what's really so
fascinating about it isn't just because
he's a Heisman Trophy winner which we
all usually do talk about it's we're
wondering is this because if he did if
he does get drafted top five top ten
does start get out there then the
transformation of the National Football
League offensive schemes from the 20th
to the 21st century would be complete
and then we're wondering just how how
small can you go right that's that's the
idea of what makes calamari so
fascinating yeah and if you're a
football fan it gives you bragging
rights over Major League Baseball they
were ready to change the rules to this
guy they give him give him a big league
contract right out of the gate and you
know let him have the 15 million dollars
so he's he's gonna be a trendsetter one
way or another and hopefully he has
success in the NFL so that we can say
well yeah this guy picked our sport over
baseball and now he's look at all the
success he's having okay
Matt thanks very much for joining we'll
see you in Indianapolis and like I said
if you want to get a seat on the Jones
bus I can I can try and arrange that for
you
I think do it well I mean it's it's like
a restaurant I think there seedings at
7:00 9:00 and 2:00 in the morning so in
the morning you know if you're gonna go
you want a good story I want to go all
right Matt take care of yourself we'll
see you thank you got Matt Miller one of
the best at bleacher report the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience